there's generally two different types of
thinking when you think about
negotiating a lot of people think
negotiation is all about a bunch of
one-night stands let me explain to what
I mean by that which is you know you do
business with them you get what you want
you win they lose and you walk away you
never have to do business ever again and
sometimes that's what you want in
business but that's not how you
negotiate with billion-dollar companies
see negotiating with a billion-dollar
company is you're dealing with pros
you're dealing with sharks you're
dealing with people that have sat in
rooms of are you dealing with people
that know how to read body language they
know how to look at your eyes I know how
to read through the bills this is not a
you know getting the 19 year old kid to
buy $5,000 program you have on your
website that's a whole different story
there's a lot of guys doing that right
now online I'm talking about really
sitting in a boardroom with a 515
billion dollar company with 20 board
members around they're asking you why
the order to business with you and
you're able to look at them without any
fear nervousness on saying this is why I
think this makes sense to do business so
how do you go about doing that that's
exactly what I'm gonna talk about today
so business look here's a couple things
you got to keep on mind some mindset a
lot of people watch boiler room oh my
gosh I want to be able to negotiate like
this guy you know man only if I can
negotiate like the guy in wolf of
wallstreet Oh only if I can negotiate
like you know this other guy the story
doesn't end well the story doesn't end
well it may be a great movie I mean I
watch it they're all fascinating believe
me i watch them as well it's
entertaining but it doesn't end well
when you're when you're dealing with
these types of guys there's a different
approach you need to take it's not there
you know you hear people saying
typically when I negotiate here's what
you say to be able to get what you
wanted that makes you ask him this but
is because you're gonna have an edge on
them you can have this nonsense
that's all mounts you got to throw all
that stuff out all of that stuff and
I'll explain to you why okay all that
stuff out when I hire somebody or I
recruit somebody or I do business with
somebody or I bring a vendor in this is
my conversation and I've said this so
many times and sometimes it doesn't work
out because that's not what they were
looking
or I'll say look I'm not doing business
with you for six months I'm not hiring
you for 12 months I'm not working with
you for 24 months I plan on being in
business with you
for the rest of my life I plan on doing
for as long as possible that's what my
plan is my plan is introduced to
business with you for 6 or 12 months my
plan isn't just for you to work with
before 6 or 12 months I'm looking for
long-term relationships and long term
business relationships so you win I win
and we continuously grow is that what
you're looking for when you look at
partnerships I've been doing business
with the same carriers for quite some
time same staff that have been with me
for 10 plus years same agents that have
been with me 10 11 plus years I've lost
many throughout the time and I've made a
lot of mistakes myself believe me I'm
not saying I haven't made the mistakes
many people chose not to work with me
but for the most part I am very clear
upfront for people to know that this is
what my expectation is and I'm going to
do this I expect this from you and if we
do this we have a winning formula
together so let me cover with you 11
points on how to negotiate with
billion-dollar companies for you to know
what they're thinking about before you
sit with them so here's my mindset
before I go in to a sit down with a 515
billion dollar company and I'm asking
them how to negotiate 12 billion dollar
company 193 billion dollar company 220
billion dollar company these are all
companies that I've sat with their CEOs
and their executives and their
accountants and their attorneys and
they're looking actually in the eyes and
can you deliver so let me cover a few
things with you one first question to
ask if I were them would I do business
with me so my first question I ask
always and you got to be able to answer
it many times I can say yes let me say
one more time if I were them would I do
business with me why is that important
to ask well are you there yet are you
somebody that's serious about this
business or you stole one foot in one
foot out are you still trying it out why
should they do business with you if
you're not all-in why should I even
consider if you're just kind of trying
it out why should they do business with
you if you're looking for one-night
stand type of an opportunity why should
they do business with you if you're a
transitional relationship person that's
coming and leaving why should they why
should that person or that company
decide to want to do business
with you and when you do that roll it
when you do that question you got to be
very brutally honest with yourself this
is not a time to pump yourself up this
is a time to take emotion out and purely
bring the logic in and say Papa Papa I
still got work to do
point number two what value do I bring
to them what value do I bring to them
you notice I'm not telling you ask this
question and ask that question not at
all I'm going to show you what we don't
have to ask any question you simply
present what value do I bring to them do
I bring value what is the value how do I
bring value what areas am I good in how
them associating with me what has it
helped them do right these are questions
you're asking number three what are you
bringing to the table forget the value
what do you bringing to the table is
their new relationship bringing to the
table is there an investment you bring
into the table is there a contract you
bring into the table is there volume you
bring you what do you bring into the
table what is that number look like what
is that thing you look like there you
bring into the table for what is your
track record so your track record what
have you done what is the things that
you've done what is your numbers look
like what are you going to bring to the
table what is your past look like and by
the way typically when you're doing
business with companies that have a lot
of money and you're dealing with you
know billion multi-billion dollar
companies they have investigators they
have people that are online
investigators they have people that go
and call every single person in the past
I've done business with a company
several and this isn't just one of them
one of the companies I did business with
in advance they did a background check
on me it was probably thirty four
hundred pages that they sent me and I
looked at how far back they went before
they said they'll do business with me
how far back 13 14 years old 18 years
old 16 years old 19 years old military
driving record of HIPPA health every
single thing before they decided a
business would be because I'll say
here's what we need to know about you
before you do business with you
so what is my track record have I
delivered why did that relationship not
work out what happened over here you
can't make things up and so I was the
best kind you were not they're going to
figure those things out so track record
on who you were while you're doing
business with them is very important
five have we shown progress of improving
before we ask for what we want so if I
go and I'm sitting there with
I'm sitting there with a vendor or a
partner and I want to ask them to
increase something - oh so the agents
can be getting paid more money and you
know I'm very transparent with our guys
so they'll generally know here's what's
going to look like you know have we have
we ourselves shown progress you know if
if the numbers are flat you don't have
leverage if the numbers are like this
you don't have a leverage you don't
especially if the uptick is not looking
good if you have progress you have
leverage if you don't have progress
there is no leverage so what are you
here for so you better believe if
there's no this they're not sitting
there you know excited about you by the
way the the Fortune 100 companies that
you negotiate with or multi-billion
dollar companies you negotiate with they
don't care about your relationship there
is no friendship they may have a beer
with you because I want to do business
with you they may take you out to a
fancy restaurant spend $600 like they
did the other night but they're not
doing it because they like the way you
look or your family or your kids you
know they're doing it because they're
gonna make money off you they have they
have shareholders they have to answer to
most of these guys are not mutual
companies and if they're mutual
companies have to report their numbers
and if they don't hit their numbers are
no longer part of the company regardless
they have numbers to perform so they're
not sitting there saying oh you're so
sweet I like you yeah we'll do business
with you it doesn't work that way
it doesn't work that way in that world
six are we a match are you bringing in
what type of business they're looking
for are you are you taking them into a
market they want to get into are you
taking them into a certain demographic
or age ethnicity or certain thing that
they want to go into are you bringing
that to them are you bringing that to
them you know if it just look at a
basketball if a basketball team already
has a center and you're another center
and another center team's not gonna have
three strong centers they may have two
in a backup they may have one in a back
up and that's it they're not going to
constitute it are you a match with this
company that you're asking whatever
you're asking for seven are we
constantly showing expansion are you
expanding are you scaling this is
different than progress because there's
a lot that can have progress but they're
all in one office you're still progress
but it's all in the same location are
you expanding are you going to new
territories are you going in new markets
are you going to new places you've never
been before is that happening
business ate or your figures growing at
a 50% rate you know if you can sell
graffiti will grow at 5% rate no one's
interested you got to show some numbers
you're going in there asking for things
and you're now growing at 50% hundred
percent rate they're not generally
interested they want to know who is this
guy that's putting up some numbers
here's what our numbers look like here's
what we're doing this is our track
record here's how we've grown you
already know the numbers we're putting
up dot dot dot
so are you grown at that pace very
critical nine are they in place are they
in a place where they're willing to
invest resources to grow their company
are they going into a year where it's
about getting tighter with spending see
these are important questions to ask I
like to ask these questions because I
want to know listen just because
companies are 550 and billion dollar
company or 420 a billion dollar company
or two billion dollar company doesn't
mean they have all the money in the
world to cut checks and all this and not
at all there are times where the market
is bad and they're hit by oil they're
hit by mortgage crisis they're hit by
election they're hit by market they're
hit by you know what happened and war
you have no idea these are important
questions to ask and generally a lot of
that information is out there for tea
but these are important questions for
you to be asking on where they're at you
can't just go in there and you know
power-play yourself it would be a very
short-term relationship okay it's hen
what kind of goes do they have for the
following year what do you guys want to
do next year we're going to be doing the
follow-on you what do you want to do
what are your main goals is it volume is
it expansion is it market as in
territory is it a certain product it
sort of launch of a product are you
trying to go international what is your
goal what is your focus what do you want
to do they'll generally tell you this is
what we have when you guys had your last
quarter or conference call what was it
calls all about what was the focus
mainly all about it's important to know
because if there's a real partnership
you want to contribute it's not about
just to know to have an edge you play
that again people eventually feel how
you want they don't want to do business
with your long-term you may have one
victory you may have a couple small
victories but the bigger you get your
rep spreads very very quickly very very
quickly you can have all the enemies in
the world I want to say negative things
about you but the people that were in
there making money with you guess what
they know about you if I go into
business with this guy we're going to
make money if I go into business with
this girl I'm gonna make money if I go
into business with this group we're
going to make money no matter what
anybody else says their track record
shows this we like to we like doing
business with them and a point number 11
is have we earned the right to ask for
more I think a lot of times people you
know just want to go in and ask ask ask
you know rule of thumb typically don't
ask for big things from anybody then
you're doing business with my number is
two to four years you know you ask you
ask you ask eventually they mute you out
it's two to four years you know unless
if you're somebody that's absolutely
crushing it and you are dominating the
market with them then they don't have a
problem because they know how important
of a relationship this is if you come
too demanding you many of these
companies are also human beings they
have their own egos they have their own
positions that they have their won they
don't want to be pushed around and
bullied around by somebody they can cut
relationships to you know you got to
understand that there's respect involved
these people are not only in business to
make money they also have a position
that they're proud of they're also have
you know amount of years that they put
into business these are people with a
pulse
they bleed there's a reason why they
mate to this level because I have a lot
of pride on where they got to and I'm
not talking in a negative way when a
basketball player has gone is team to a
certain point there's a certain level of
pride there's a certain level of fire
you're not talking to somebody hey come
and push me around and ask for things
that's not going to happen but when you
do that so now people say so now what do
you do
I simply restate every one of these
points what do you mean by that Pat let
me tell you listen if I were you at the
business with me here's why here's what
we bring to the table with you okay
here's a value we bring to you here's
our track record we like you because
you've done this I think you'll like us
because we do this we've been progress
and you know our numbers I believe we're
a match we're constantly expanding our
business we've been growing out of 58%
rate based on what you told me and where
your market is right now with the
company I feel it's a good fit for us to
do business now you told me your goals
for the following year we can help you
hit it and I believe we won't earn the
right to ask you for XYZ it's simple it
isn't that complicated and when you do
that and you sit there and negotiate it
with that group they sit out there and
say okay let us think about it
it's not going to be I need to know an
answer now I don't do it that way I said
when can you give me an answer
Friday 5:00 o'clock fair enough many
times they'll say no and I'll say ok in
my mind I may say you know I haven't
earned it yet or I may regroup and ask
why not and don't give me an explanation
well because your numbers are this this
this this system we'd like to see this
and then I'll say by one would you want
to see this and if we do this can you do
this they may say no matter when you
ever do this this is not something we're
going to you know work with you on okay
great how about if I do this ok this but
then there's a discussion this isn't
like you know positioning and power play
you know honestly them when you work
with these guys yesterday sharp they're
sharks yes they're pros yes they are but
you know they want to make money so if
you have a way for them to make money
they're open to it and if it's something
that's aligned with their philosophy and
where they're going they'll generally
open with it but you can you can pull
off all those magic tricks that people
teach and all these other negotiators
teach you so you look at me throw a drop
you can do all those you know lotion
potion type of stuff that people talk
about when it comes down to dealing with
people who know what they're doing you
better bring your a-game and just be
real with people do not play games with
people they don't like that you don't
like that they definitely don't like
that and they can read through the BS
and you know it may not be a good
negotiating trip for you now maybe two
years from now maybe three years or
maybe five years some but ten years from
that they're eventually going to say
this is a real part and we're going to
do business with and that takes time but
if you're a long term type of person and
that reputation goes out there that your
long term type of person people
eventually will get passed you know
whether they like you or not they'll get
past the fact that at least I respect
the fact that this person is a stand-up
person and they deliver and they're
working their butts off to make sure
their numbers being hit so go through
this if you want to get this PDF go on
my website click on the link on the
bottom we should put a link somewhere
here probably that'll say Patrick made a
video but I put the exact link on the
bottom here for you to go to the site
and subscribe to my newsletter on the
bottom you'll see it on my website
subscribe to the newsletter right under
the link you'll be able to get the
points send out you with my notes on
eleven things to be thinking about
before you negotiate with more
not all companies you got any questions
comment on the bottom as well we do get
back to the questions that people post
thanks for watching take care